IMPROVEMENT
IPROVEMENT
IMPOVEMENT
IMPROEMENT
IMPROVEENT
IMPROVEMET
IMPROVEMENT.
[APPLAUSE]
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS BULL AND
HIS RED BALL HE IS HAVING SO
MUCH FUN PROBABLY MORE FUN HE
LOVES THAT GO ANYWHERE WITH
IT.
SO MUCH JOY THAT BALL AND THAT
BALL TOGETHER THEY ARE
INSEPARABLE.
LOOK AT THEM.
THEY GO EVERYWHERE TOGETHER
NOBLE HAS EVER BEEN AS
ECSTATIC FOR.
>> HE PUNCTURED HIS BALL THE
BULL HAS LOST HIS BALL.
LOOK HOW SAD HE LOOKS.
HE IS HEARTBROKEN.
I WONDER HOW CNN FEELS ABOUT
THIS SAD BOWL IF IT WERE TRUMP.
>> OR HOW DOES MSNBC FEEL
ABOUT THIS BAD BOWL IF IT WAS
TRUMP?
HOW WOULD "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
FEEL ABOUT THIS SAD BOWL OF IT
WERE TRUMP?
[LAUGHTER]
I WILL BE HONEST I JUST WANTED
VIDEOTAPE OF THE BULL.
[LAUGHTER]
FOR THE MEDIA TO FEEL GOOD
SOMETHING MUST FEEL BAD SO IT
WAS LIKE CHRISTMAS AND SPRING
BREAK COMBINED THIS WEEK THE
PARENTS WERE OUT OF TOWN IN
HANOI TRYING TO GET THROUGH A
CAKE OR IN DC AND MICHAEL
:-COLON IS THERE A STRIPPER.
[LAUGHTER]
INTO THE
A GIBBERING RAT TO THE PROCESS
THAT BAD NEWS MAKES THEM FEEL
SO GOOD.
SPIN FOR A SECOND TIME WITHOUT
A NEW CLEAR AGREEMENT.
>> NOW HE IS COMING UP AGAINST
REAL WORLD INTERNATIONAL
REALITIES AND HE CAN CLOSE THE
DEAL.
>> A VERY ROUGH AND ROCKY 24
HOURS FOR THE PRESIDENT BACK
IN WASHINGTON AND HERE IN
HANOI HEADED BACK EMPTY-HANDED.
>> SO FIRST THEY SPEND A WEEK
SAYING HE WILL GIVE UP TOO
MUCH THEN THEY WHINE BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T GIVE AWAY A THING.
IF I WASN'T SO PIED RIGHT NOW
I WOULD SAY THEY ARE BIASED.
WE ALL WANT WORLD PEACE BY
WALKING AWAY AS PART OF
NEGOTIATING BUT THE MEDIA SEES
IT JUST AS THE WHOLE THING
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE THE
GUY DOING THE DEAL IF YOU
BELIEVE WE ALREADY GAVE UP A
LOT WITH THE MEETING THEN WHO
NEEDS DIALOGUE AT ALL?
WHY WASTE TIME?
THE DOWNSIDE GETS A MILLION SO
STOP FEEDING INTO IT WITH
PEOPLE WE DON'T LIKE DON'T BE
PASSIVE AS REJECTING DIALOGUE
EVEN WHEN THERE IS PROOF THAT
TRUMPS WORDS DID MAKE IT
CHEAPER DO YOU REMEMBER HAWAII
LAST YEAR?
PEOPLE WERE FREAKING OUT AS
BUREAUCRATS IN HAWAII WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
COMPUTER PASSWORD.
I AM A JACKASS.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT THAT FAILED IN NORTH KOREA
BECAUSE THE DRUG SUPPLY IS LOW
LOOK AT THE ECONOMY.
IT IS PRETTY GOOD SO TO WANT
NORTH KOREA TO FAIL THAT TRUMP
HAD TO APPEAR IT WOULD BE SEEN
AS A CONCESSION SO DOES THE
MEDIA ACTUALLY WORK AGAINST
WORLD PEACE?
THAT IS CRAZY.
RIGHT?
.
>> HE MAKES A STRONG CASE.
[LAUGHTER]
MEANWHILE THE MEDIA SAW
MICHAEL :-COLON AS THE
SHUFFLEBOARD AND HE OBLIGED
DELIVERING THE DRUGS THE MEDIA
DROOLS OVER.
>> HE IS A RACIST, HE IS A CON
MAN.
HE IS A CHEAT.
[LAUGHTER]
.
>> HOW ORIGINALLY THINK KATHY
GRIFFITH HAS THAT TATTOOED ON
HER BACK.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT THE MEDIA AIDED UP AND
CLIMBED UP HIS WE ARE LIKE THE
INTOXICATED EARWIGS.
>> WE ARE HUMBLED BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY A LOT OF THE
PERSONAL ANECDOTES HAVE TO
RING TRUE.
>> HE SAID WHAT HE FEARED FOR
THE COUNTRY.
>> I REALLY PROUD OF THIS GUY
UP THERE BECAUSE HE HAS THE
WORLD AGAINST HIM.
>> YOU KNOW, WHY HE IS
PROUD?
BECAUSE THESE CHEESE BALLS ARE
CLOSE FRIENDS.
THEY DON'T STRIKE ME AS MEN
WHO WEAR SPEEDO'S TO BREAKFAST.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT IS WHAT A CHEESE BALL
DOES THAT SINCE MICHAEL
OFFERED NO COLLUSION THEY HAD
TO DO REAL EVALUATIONS.
>> IS A PRESIDENTIAL LAWYER
SAY WE INFLATED ASSETS.
>> HOLY CRAP.
THE RICH GUY INFLATED ASSETS
THAT SOUNDS VAGUELY KARDASHIAN.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
.
>> THANK YOU I WILL TAKE IT.
THIS IS A PATHETIC JOKE THEY
NEED MORE WRONGDOING.
SO HERE IS THREE BAD THINGS
DONALD TRUMP DID THAT THEY
SHOULD REPORT ON NUMBER ONE HE
WANTS LAUNDERED MONEY.
YES PRICKLY LEFT A 20 IN HIS
SUIT WHEN IT WENT TO THE
CLEANERS.
NUMBER TWO HE ONCE SHOT A MAN
A DIRTY LOOK FOR BEING RUDE.
NUMBER THREE HE BEAT HIS CHILD
THAT YACHTS THE.
[LAUGHTER]
MAYBE THAT WILL SUE THE WOUND
OF 2016 AFTER ALL THAT IS ALL
THE NEWS IS NO DEAL WITH KIM
JUNG-UN?
TAKE THAT AND SOMEBODY ELSE'S
RACIST?
KAVANAUGH?
COVINGTON.
EVERYONE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
THE DRUG TO MAKE THEM FEEL
BETTER THAT DID NOT WORK THAT
IS WHY THE HEARING MATTERED SO
MUCH.
>> I FEAR IF HE LOSES THE
ELECTION IN 2020 THERE WILL
NEVER BE A PEACEFUL TRANSITION
OF POWER.
>> LUCKY FOR YOU YOU WILL BE
SAFE IN PRISON.
[LAUGHTER]
BY THE WAY, STORMY DANIELS
ACTUALLY SENT HIM A NOTE TO
SAY I AM PROUD OF YOU.
LE SHE IS PROUD OF SOMETHING
THAT FILM REVENGE OF THE.
[BLEEP]
I CAN TELL YOU DID NOT PLEASE
HER MOTHER.
[LAUGHTER]
I SOUGHT THREE TIMES AND IT
WAS DISGUSTING.
[LAUGHTER]
[BLEEP]
I WILL KEEP SAYING IT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO BE PIT.
[LAUGHTER]
SO THAT HEARING WAS A BINGE OF
GRACE GREASY JUNKFOOD GOING IN
AND GO OUT YOU FEEL GROSS
AFTERWARDS BUT THAT IS THE
MEDIA DIET.
NO ROUGHAGE.
.
>> YOU FIND YOURSELF ROOTING
AGAINST THE COUNTRY JUST
BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIKE THE
PRESIDENT?
THAT HE MAY MAKE A BAD
DECISION WITH CUT ONE - - KIM
JUNG-UN?
.
>> THIS CANNOT BE HAPPENING.
>> HE IS GOING TO GIVE AWAY
THE STORE.
>> SOME WANTED TO FAILED
BECAUSE THEN WE ARE BACK TO
SQUARE NUMBER ONE SPENT THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT I WANT.
>> TRY OPTIMA X SIMPLE
ONE-A-DAY PILL TO CLEAR YOUR
DESIRES FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
FAIL.
WITH A MORE POSITIVE OUTCOME
FOR ANY SITUATION.
>> I NEVER MET MY EX-WIFE'S
NEW BOYFRIEND NOW I CAN SEE HE
DOES MAKE HER HAPPY AND SHE IS
HAPPY WHY DOES THAT BOTHER ME?
THANK YOU CHAD.
[LAUGHTER]
.
>> I WENT TO CHURCH EVERY DAY.
BUT THEN I SAW THE COMPANY
STOCK WAS UP SO MAYBE SHE
DIDN'T DESERVE THE PROMOTION.
THINK YOU.
THANK YOU GOD FOR NOT
ANSWERING MY PRAYERS ABOUT
BARBARA.
[LAUGHTER]
.
>> YOU ARE WRONG ELIMINATING A
NUCLEAR THREAT IN THE KOREAN
WAR?